Google is undoubtedly changing the way
that humans search and how websites are
being shown on the Google SERPs. If
you've missed out on SEO rankings and
growing your website in the past, this
is the biggest opportunity for you
because the playing field is level and
if you follow the strategies that I
mentioned in today's video, you can get
ahead get cited by ChatGPT, show up in
AI search, and get more targeted traffic
over to your website or to your brand in
this new era of SEO. Let's go ahead and
get started. If you want to get the full
SOP of the difference between SEO and
GEO and how to optimize for GEO in 2026
and beyond, just comment GEO below and
I'll send you over this full slide deck.
So, number one,
SEO is no longer about ranking, it's
about becoming the cited source. So,
there's going to be less and less clicks
to websites even if they're ranked
number one. So, you need to be able to
show up in the search box when someone
asks the AI a question. So, an old SEO
question would be, can this page rank
for this specific keyword? We're not
asking that question anymore. We're
asking, can my page support the user's
full answer journey? Before, we would
think of SEO from a keyword and a page
that tries to optimize for that specific
keyword. But in today's day and age, we
need to think about fan out questions
that are related to that search queries.
If someone's thinking about the best
coffee beans, they may be also thinking
about the best way to prepare, the best
product, the best equipment to buy,
the different types of coffee beans,
right? So, we need to now think about
not just only ranking for that keyword,
but being able to support that user's
full answer journey. So, everything
within our page needs to be related to
kind of think of people also ask
questions. Those are what we're going to
need to optimize for within our articles
and within our blog posts. For example,
if you take a look at this article from
Word Rocket, it's a news article on
Anthropic's new
features that they have. So, we can see
right away we have the quick answer, and
then below that we have what is the
project, how does it how is it choosing
to expand, what types of infrastructure
are included in the expansion, what
specifies cybersecurity, what risk does
Anthropic see in the future.
Is it to
only for government or project sector
and some other questions here. So, we
see that we're not optimizing for this
specific keyword and try to stuff it in
the H1s, H2s. No, we're going out or
we're asking different questions because
when it comes to getting cited by AI,
this full article will not be shown.
It's going to be part of this article
that is most relevant to the search
query. So, if someone asks, "How does
Anthropic expand Project Glass Wing to
critical infrastructure?" Right? We're
going to see that the AI is going to
take this specific section and show it
to the user in Google search or in
ChatGPT. So, we're not trying to rank
the full page, we're trying to rank or
we're trying to get specific paragraphs
to be shown and cited by AI. The second
old SEO question is, "Is my title tag
optimized?" And the new AI search
question is, "Is the answer clear enough
to extract and cite?" As I mentioned
before, the answer needs to be very,
very clear. And that's why Word Rocket
is such a good writer because we've
already
created our geo prompts to make sure
that the answer of for that query is
easily found. So, we see the quick
answer right away in every one of our
articles. So, again, we see this
secondary article here. We see the quick
answer right away. We see when it was
updated because fresh content matters.
And each section of our article needs to
be independently useful and verifiable.
So again, going back over to
Wordtracker, we can see here each one of
these paragraphs here is independent on
its own because it asks a question and
then it answers the question below. Ask
another question that's related and
answer the questions below. Again, it
asks another question and we can see
here it answers it right below that.
Now, verifiable is very, very important.
That means our content our our article
content needs to be verifiable by
recognizable or trustworthy sources.
Now, we can see here that we have
in-text citations that Wordtracker
does research beforehand and then uses
that within the article. We've
implemented this from a while now
because we know it's important to have
references. So we can see here under our
article, we have live web references and
these are all
verifiable
and trustworthy sources.
So again, if we click on any one of
these links, we can see that they
actually are trusted sources, not just
broken links, and we naturally include
that within our article with these
citations. Right? So this again allows
the AI to create content that's much
more verifiable to increase the likeness
that will actually get cited. So AI
search selects paragraphs, not just
pages. So some of the mechanisms that we
need to do is we need to ensure that the
query interpretation is important. So
here are some things that we need to
keep in mind. We need to cover the
concept cloud around the topic, not just
one phrase. So we need to have a concept
instead of thinking about writing for a
keyword. We need to keep pages
crawlable, accessible, and internally
linked, and semantically clear. Internal
linking is automatic on Wordtracker. We
need to place strong answers and
evidence, author signals, and updates
near the top. As you saw in my previous
article, you have that information of
the quick answer and the key takeaways
right at the top of the article. And we
need to make claim specific source fresh
and easy to associate with the URL. And
again, going back over to Word Rocket,
we see those sources
are easily attainable and they're
high-quality sources as well. So again,
it So again, repeating this for opening
paragraph, direct answer, for headings,
natural language and questions for
paragraphs, one idea per concise, it
needs to be self-contained, tables,
tables are really good, and evidence,
and then a trust block. So if you can
get original evidence, then this creates
a citation gravity. So in Word Rocket,
if you head over to
your brand voice and your knowledge, and
you edit any one of these brand voice
and knowledges that you have, you can
actually upload your knowledge base. So
your knowledge base can be your custom
citations or your custom knowledge that
you're using or your custom
So your knowledge base can be your
custom findings and your own original
data that you want to use within your
article. So if you have original data,
you can upload it onto Word Rocket and
use that to write your article and we'll
reference that within your reference
section. So again, increases the
likeness that your content will get
cited by AI. And here's a 30-day sprint
that you can use to become more citable
by AI. Again, if you want to get this
full SOP, just comment GEO below and
I'll send it over to you guys. And if
you'd like to use the best SEO and GEO
optimized writing tool, it is Word
Rocket by far. As you can see, we've put
hours and hours of getting this tool
right and is optimized for today's
changing AI search landscape. So if you
want to get ahead, try out Word Rocket
for completely free. I'll leave a link
below and I'll see you guys in the next
video. Take care.